one more thing i want to briefly touch
on related to the uvalde school shooting
we now are very familiar in the united
states with this circle where nothing
happens okay and i know that i'm
sounding negative and cynical but this
is typically the way that it goes
you can start the circle anywhere i'll
start with the mass shooting mass
shooting happens okay
explosive media coverage for several
days a week a couple of weeks tragedy
uh something must be done but not too
much because people need their gun
rights and you got to stop bad guys with
guns with good guys with guns and okay
we don't want to do too much but
something must be done it's a tragedy
okay well since you can't
really get anything done because oh we
can't restrict we can't do that we end
with thoughts and prayers and there's
vigils and all of these different things
okay and then a little bit of time
passes and the more guns in more places
people get really defensive about doing
anything to make it harder to get guns
and to reduce the supply of guns
floating around so you get gridlock and
nobody ends up doing anything and then
people forget about the last major
shooting now in this case you know when
we say we're back to normal
the last mass shooting was like
the last major
nationally significant mass shooting
because there were a bunch in between it
was buffalo 11 days ago so back to
normal now means it's been like a week
since the last major mass shooting but
we're quote back to normal
and nothing gets done
and then there's another mass shooting
and the cycle starts all over again
except it's just happening more quickly
because like i said the last one was 11
days ago we weren't even really back to
normal it's just now normal
that there's been a mass shooting a few
days ago
that's the cycle
and unless you break that cycle sadly
nothing's going to change let me know
your thoughts find me on twitter at
dpakman